a problem worthy of attack proves it's
worth by fighting back and that's what
Fermat's Last Theorem was doing it was
fighting back so we're talking about
fellas Last Theorem and I suppose the
place to start is with fermata PA da
fermo who was a 17th century
mathematician living and working in
France not working as a mathematician
but working as a judge and every evening
he'd go home and maths was his hobby one
evening he he was looking at an equation
which looks a bit like Pythagoras
equation which I suppose is x2 squared
plus y squared equals Z squared and he
was looking for a whole number solutions
to that equation and there are lots you
know there's 3 squared plus 4 squared 5
squared so that's a whole number
solution to X 1 plus y squared equals x
squared now Elmar asked himself the
question what about if I change this
equation so instead of it being x
squared what about if it's X cubed or X
to the fourth power or Y to the fourth
power are there solutions to that
equation so in general we're talking
about X to the n plus y to the N equals
Z to the N where n is bigger than 2 does
that equation
have any whole number solution he
thought about it for a while and
couldn't find any whole number solutions
and then he went one step further not
only could he not find any whole number
solutions he believed he'd found an
argument he believed he'd find a proof
that showed without any doubt whatsoever
there were no whole number solutions so
this is kind of weird because we have
one equation x squared plus y squared
equals Z squared that has not just one
solution it actually has an infinite
number of solutions and then you have an
infinite number of equations X cubed
plus y cubed equals n cubed x to the
fourth plus y to the fourth equals led
to the full an infinite number of
equations which apparently have no
solutions and fir might discover this
proof and he wrote in the margin of a
book he was reading that evening called
the arithmetic by diophantus and he
wrote in the margin of his book he wrote
I have a truly marvelous proof which
this margin is too narrow to contain
hanck margin --is x aguar 'test non
kappa root in latin in other words i
know how to prove that this equation has
no solutions
but I don't have the space to write a
debt and then he drops dead it very much
was a secret proof which he never wrote
down and then after his death his son
Samuel Clement I think rediscovered this
book which had this marginal note I have
a truly marvelous proof a demonstrative
morale bellum which this margins
tannerite contained and in fact the book
is full of these little annoying notes I
can prove this but I've got to go and
feed the cat I can prove this but I've
got to go and wash my hair so firm I was
quite annoying in this respect so his
son published a new version of the book
the arithmetic abide diophantus but with
all the fair Mars little notes printed
in the text and people would look at
these notes and they would say well
firma says he can prove this let's try
it and one by one people rediscovered
the missing proofs and in every case
we're firmer firmer said I have a proof
he was right there was a proof except in
this one example here Fermat's Last
Theorem is called fair Mao's Last
Theorem because it was the last one that
anybody could actually find the proof
for and of course because it's the last
one that anyone can prove it's the most
precious one it's the one that's most
desirable and the more that people try
them or they fail the more wonderful it
becomes and this goes on for decades it
goes on for centuries right through to
the 20th century where people are
desperate to rediscover what fair Mars
proof might have been is that they have
widely held that he had done it or had
he disclaimed like was he telling the
truth
I think by the time we get to the 20th
century it's quite clear that this is an
incredibly complex problem it's simple
to drop down in a few scribbles what the
what the question is it's easy to
describe the problem the proof is
clearly profound and probably beyond
fair Mars reached to be honest
some people say firm I was just fooling
around it was just a trick that he left
something in his book that he knew were
trouble subsequent generations I think
that's least likely some people say that
he did have a genuine proof and it's
beautiful in its elegant in its 17th
century and and we could kind of
rediscover that proof but we're just not
quite clever in
I think that's possible but I unlike Lee
I think the most likely explanation is
it fair my thought he had a proof
because he was working on his own and
because he didn't show this proof to
anybody else nobody could tell him oh
there's a mistake there you know line
three has got it's got something wrong
with it and and and that's very likely
because we know that subsequent
generations of mathematicians thought
they'd found a proof and then they
publish it and people would tear it
apart and they'd find the error so what
we're looking for is not fair mass proof
which was probably flawed but we're
looking for some kind of proof to see
whether firm I was right all along
it has a happy ending and it starts with
a ten-year-old child a chap called
Andrew Wiles who was reading a book one
day he's growing up in Cambridge he went
to the library he got a book called the
last problem by et bell and the book is
all about firmers Last Theorem and and
little Andrew Wiles age 10 decided that
he was going to rediscover the missing
proof because a bright ten-year-old can
understand the problem a bright
ten-year-old doesn't realize what
they're letting themselves in for but
but that's another story and he tries he
talks about about his school teachers
about the problem he talks to his a
level teachers about the problem he goes
to university talks to his undergraduate
lectures about the problem he does a PhD
and still this problem is obsessing him
I think he was about in his late 30s by
this time he was a Princeton professor
there was something called a tan er
Monsieur Mereau conjecture which I kind
of think we don't really want to get
into if the moment which had been
proposed in the 50s or a conjecture is
an idea that we don't know whether it's
true or not but somebody's putting it on
the table
somebody proved there was a link between
these two conjectures in as much as if
you could prove most of the tan er
Monsieur Mereau conjecture you would get
Fermat's Last Theorem for free so
somehow thermals Last Theorem is
embedded in this other conjecture and
Andrew Wiles his childhood passion his
childhood obsession is reignited because
he thinks that an Italian Monsieur
Mereau conjecture is worth a go you know
he thinks he can get his teeth into that
but but it's still a Cray
easy thing to try and do and so because
it was such an absurd and ambitious
challenge Wiles didn't tell anybody
about it he worked on it in complete
secrecy
he started not attending committee
meetings he started going to his office
less and less he started to focus on
this problem once again not because it
was a Tony Armas camera conjecture but
because it would give him fellas Last
Theorem for free and for seven years he
worked in complete secrecy and at the
end of seven years he suddenly realized
that he had Talia Masha Mora and if he
had tanamashu Mora
he had a proof of Fermat's Last Theorem
he went to Cambridge he presented his
proof on a blackboard I think was a
three part lecture the world cheered he
was the front page of the New York Times
he was on CNN he was everywhere but the
sting in the tail is that in any
mathematical proof you have to have a
checked you have to have it refereed and
published and when it went through the
checking process somebody found a
mistake Wiles assuming he could fix it
but the more he tried to unravel this
problem the worse it became and it
became a huge embarrassment you know
you've been lauded as a greatest
mathematician of the 20th century
you're a hero figure and now you have to
admit you made a mistake and it took a
whole year but at the end of that year
Angelo Wiles working with a chap called
Richard Taylor managed to fix the proof
I think it's a bit like the Terminator
film I often talk about as we know and
you just when you've slain the monster
when you've killed the Terminator he
comes back to life and and you have to
fight in one last time and somebody on
one mathematician I think Piet Hein once
wrote a problem worthy of attack proves
it's worth by fighting back and that's
what Fermat's Last Theorem was doing it
was fighting back but whilst proved that
he was too good and of course what Wiles
proved is that firm I was right this
equation X to the M plus y to the N
equals Z to the N and bigger than two
has no whole number solutions and that's
the end of the story if you'd like to
see a bit more from this interview with
Simon I've got some extra footage I'll
put a link in the description
Simon's also got a book about Fermat's
Last Theorem that's excellent
I recommend it links below and just this
week he's got a new book out funny about
that
it's all about mathematics and the
Simpsons and I think anyone who likes
numberphile is going to love this one
I'll put a link below but he's also done
an interview with me about Fermat's Last
Theorem in the Simpsons which I think
you'll all enjoy and I'll put that onto
numberphile really soon but in the
meantime lots of links below I'll put a
link to the wiles paper a few other bits
and pieces that I want you to see so so
have a good look